si on décidait de vendre rembourserait
la dette qu'ils enchaîna occupe-toi de
ce dossier ils envoient quelqu'un à
faire une inspection
williama vous devez être l'assistante de
Monsieur Randall son pilote en chef en
fait
la ceinture
de toucher quelque chose
oui c'est ça de leur tonnerre c'est trop
papa et pour vous will vous avez monté
une affaire avec votre femme je suis
célibataire intéressant
tu peux me dire quand je pourrais
trouver le temps de sortir j'aimerais
que tu passes plus de temps à terre si
tu veux pas que la définition voler sans
toi tu as répété pour me sortir ça ouais
dans le miroir
ne commence pas à t'attacher ferme cette
compagnie et rentre vite à la maison
[Musique]
vous arrivez comme ça
comme prenez un peu de vacances pour les
biens le cyclone défonce sur nous c'est
une promesse
que ce soit fait le toi-même
franchement c'est pas un vrai paradis
il y a 8 jours c'est le dernier endroit
sur terre où je voulais aller
[Musique]
parfois la meilleure façon d'avancer
cette prendre un nouvel envol
on voit pas ça à Londres